Luke here with the outo boys YouTube
channel I'm here in the swamps of
Florida and for the next two weeks I'm
fishing catching pythons hunted Gators
spear fishing eating good food and I'm
bringing you guys along for the
ride train I got the sun only rain
I want to crash and on this
pain nothing will last inside this leg
take me far away past this mediocre days
I need to stop this
bird say can you help me un
learn
this all right guys welcome to Fort
Meers
[Music]
Florida alligators there's
alligators
right oh here we
are oh what do you think it is oh very
nice look at
this it's got a walkr
shower this place is
huge oh look at
this this is nice that's
nice look at this dock oh we're going to
have to do some fishing off
this there he is there he is look at
this get him get him get him here here
there you go got you got him got a
little chameleon that's cool go show
Doby it's really cool see he's trying to
bite me all right well back out welcome
to Cape Coral Florida are you excited to
be here I'm so excited it's gorgeous
it's nice to get away from the snow huh
yeah yeah I'm going to go hit the store
I'm going to get some
supplies
all right guys dinner's
ready come sit out here by the fire Lucy
on the key well back home there's about
3 ft of snow in our front yard so this
is pretty nice and bean shirtless and
bean
shirtless make you
cold oh I was so hungry well guys it has
been a long day but we are so glad to be
here we've got so many fun things
planned for the next week or so I'll see
you you guys in the morning I've got to
get some
rest oh good morning it is 11:30 in the
morning we slept about 12 hours last
night we were really really
[Music]
tired want to eat by the pool I'm going
to
[Music]
feel the cool
Jacob you like that it's so good thank
you I love
this all right I think it's time to do a
little fish in
here all right there we go just a little
bit of
shrimp all right we're going to see if
we can't catch like a mangr snapper or
some sheep's head or something little
fish musing with it oh there we go there
we
go see that that's a little baby sheep's
head when they get bigger these are
delicious pretty little
guy oh little hardhead catfish this is a
saltwater catfish here in Florida that's
really common they have this really
sharp poisonous spine on their dorsal
fin and on each of their pcal fins so
you got to grab them really carefully so
you don't get stabbed you can eat them
and I have and they're okay but not my
favorite but they put up a good fight
this is so much fun I'm just sitting
here fishing and the kids are having a
ball in the pool
Jacob Jacob are you having a great time
and I was facing death you you were
facing death yes
wait
devil had a great day this is so
relaxing oh we've needed this hey to you
having fun yeah
we have spent the whole day fishing
eating and playing in the pool and I
have zero
regrets a good
morning well my in-laws are joining us
on this trip it looks like they just
arrived hi you guys made
it yeah come on in now we originally
planned to do a charter today let's see
if everyone wants to do it boys you want
to go out on a boat no no boat would you
rather rest and relax or go out on a
boat probably rest and relax bega do you
want to go out on the boat yes yeah all
right all right we'll see you guys in a
little bit your parents walked through
the door and we pawned the kids off them
in like two seconds flat nobody wanted
to go on the boat but us turn left
on welcome to Santa Bel
Island so me and Becka are going on a
shelling Charter we're going to take a
boat to a mostly uninhabited Island that
has some of the best shelling here in
the
US all right I think that's our boat
okayy never been a visitor but to go to
an island just a little bit north of
here called K Costa or Kaio Costa Costa
Kosta kasta
kasta
the sheer volume of shells here is
amazing look at this is just a mound of
shells solid sea shells there's more
shells than sand on this beach I know
it's a little
Pokey oh that looks like it's alive
reach it look at that yes that poor
sponge he'll never make it back to his
pineapple under the sea these
clamshells the previous tenant hasn't
left yet so we'll oh beautiful sand
dollar yeah that's nice well thanks to
poor time management and poor weather
this morning we had a really late start
so we only have about 20 minutes of
Shelly today but Becca's not complaining
she's just jazzed to be here yay
look at that little Crab
Claw oh there's nice
one yeah look at that yeah oh babe you
having a good time I had a great time a
good one oh yeah there nice we came to
this island about 4 years ago and we
just found so many shells it was insane
we're really trying to restrain
ourselves and not bring back as many
this
time look at the size of that clam shell
nice nice side that's a nice one oh look
at that yeah that's a pretty
one oh look at that
one yeah sea
urchin show faster Becca we're out of
time it was like time to turn around
like 10 minutes ago but this is like
Becca's version of one more
cast I told think it's time to turn
around she just ran away for me Becca I
think we need to turn around we got 12
minutes all right Becca we need to go oh
look there's a big shell over here come
get
it there go we need to run babe now we
need to get all the way around the point
in 10
minutes oh the sun set eyes off the
ground oh look there's the one dang it I
just told her not to
look
oh oh that's a pile of shells look at
that a big pile of shells we got more
than I thought we woulded to do every
night you okay woo thank you very much
we had a great time you Becca was that
fun it was so fun I'm glad you enjoyed
that lots of
shells
hello
was glad I wasn't me this time not bad
for about 30 40 minutes of shelling huh
we had more time we could have done
really well but I've got to hurry up and
eat some dinner and get out of here cuz
me and Tommy we're going python
hunting I love you be we'll see you
tomorrow I'll try my best not to get
eaten stay up yeah we got about a 2hour
drive buddy we need popsicles but
uh
[Music]
well it's almost midnight we're going to
get to bed we got to get up really early
to go hunt pythons I'll see you guys
then
even there's a
peacock hey
peacock Tommy are you psyched up yes you
ready to catch a python yes so me and
Tommy are going into the Everglades
we're going to be hunting invasive
pythons it's it's Amy Amy yep and Dave
Dave meet both of you this is Tommy and
I'm Luke welcome aboard
woohoo berby python are invasive species
it's absolutely devastating the wildlife
here in Southern Florida when Hurricane
Andrew hit a reptile breeding center was
destroyed and thousands of burmes python
hatchlings escaped into the wild and
established a breeding population here
so we're going to see if we can't find
and remove some Burmese
pythons
it's winter time here in the Everglades
and during this time the pythons come
onto these islands to breed so we're
going to go in those islands and see if
we can't find enormous snakes now Tom
when we get into that thick brush I need
you to pretend you're wounded that'll
attract the pythons got it oh that's
perfect we might get a gator too
oh these python average about 8 ft long
but they can get up to 20 ft long
they're extremely well camouflaged and
they'll sit out in the open spots and
try to bask in the Sun and if we find
one we're going to have to wrestle it
out of this
brush those invasive snails yeah it's an
apple snail shell that's crazy you want
to hold on to that give that to Mama
yeah you know mama loves shells
OT here and so that's why it's it's very
weather dependent with these guys
because all right we checked out one
Island we're going to go drive down and
check out
another I can hold
these so we got kind of these open spots
a little bit of ferns and lots of
sunlight that's where we're looking for
the
pythons little snake
skeleton that's
something what'd you find Tom Tommy and
Amy found a snake egg a native species a
black racer the snakes come here to
breed because it's one of the few places
up out of the water we're surrounded by
Miles and Miles of swamp python oh
python nope it's a little ribbon
[Music]
snake he'll musk a lot he'll stink
butake look at that little ribbon snake
Tom rib snake stinky I saw this one that
was really thick hey you're a cute
little little nope
rope snakes excrete a musk like a skunk
so my hand
stink wipe off the snake butt
smell a lot of people
from Amy just found the skin of a
Burmese python it's over here too oh do
you see it right there going all the way
back oh yeah yeah uh this is probably
like a 9 9f footer maybe uh oh here's it
head see the little eyeballs right there
so we're going to look around and see if
we can't find
him sounds like Tommy found a python
egg what's that got one try down let me
see let me check it out it'll be last
dude you're
right
I'm nice nice cool coming back every
year there you go check it out that's a
Burmese python egg right there
you see where the baby burst out right
there good spot Tom you want to hold on
to that yeah
sweet good find Tom yeah
yep there's a native snake right over
there it's called the black
racer good job baby caught that look at
that the eyes on that he was trying to
bite me a little bit so he might he
might get you just FY eye
oh here look let him go we'll let him go
wow that is a fasc oh yeah now my hand
smells like butt again it's a good sign
we saw that black racer if it's out
sunning itself then the Burmese pythons
are going to be out too most of them all
but one that one is still check it out
these are turtle eggs they got dug up a
lot of them got eaten and there's this
one still
whole
that oh look at this the shed skin of a
raser yeah look at
that
yeah
I yeah cuz they're over there right
now there's another black eraser in
[Music]
there you pick up that yeah yeah careful
he W yeah he probably
you but he want yeah there you go gent
with him yeah see how he's shedding
right there and see his skin starting to
come
off the snake is there you
go empty shelf empty shelf oh look at
that wow it's been a week old look at
that that's
crazy tail is right here so we might
have to jump on it all right oh I see
that all right is it down in that oh I
see it this is a good one it head's it
head's going off that direction isn't it
yep it head is over here this is a
really good
one here get head
Tommy grab
grab okay step on it head too where's
theum got you yeah there we go got you
look at that oh nice ho he stinks yeah
look at that he smells like just like oh
I like so this right here is a Burmese
python and he is squirting his musk all
over cuz he is upset here you grab that
tail Tom sure here unwrap your dad now
you got to you got to pull it tight pull
it tight there we go there we go going
to unwrap him stretch him stretch him
out yeah pull him out pull him out go I
think he's a 10f footer 10 atast he's
got my look at that it's still numb
feels like he weighs about 30 40 pounds
maybe so this is a male python check it
out it's Got Claws like a little toe
claw right there one on that side and
one on that side so you know technically
snakes do have legs they're just very
very tiny the male claws are bigger than
the female claws right
absolutely there you go there we go all
right Tommy we get a
picture give me a smile well these
snakes Mak are an invasive species so
we've got to go ahead and euthanize it I
can't feel your arm you getting a blood
pressure
test that's really important like we the
ground all right now we're going to go
put a tape measure on this
thing 4 in 10t 4 in all right the big
snake our average is between six and
nine yeah you're over that you're over
the average wo I'm above average my mom
is so
proud oh my God Co y
well there we go hey we smell bad we
smell bad wow when you smell like snake
butt you've had a successful day it's a
successful day really happy that we
could be a part of it well it's getting
late it's starting to cool off and when
it cools off the pythons going to hiding
so I think that's it for today and wow
it's been awesome we got that was a nice
python wasn't it it was a good one it
was a really good
python to give up yeah you know
guys thank you so much that was so much
fun if you're in Southern Florida and
you want to catch a Burmese python check
out the python Huntress I'll put a link
to their website in the video
description below make sure to check it
out yeah yeah you let me know how the hi
ey goes and what I need to pay for that
I'm definitely tanning that hide all
right thanks guys bye guys thank you now
you can technically eat bur's pythons
but they are not good I have eaten one
one time it's like rubbery chicken
flavored string cheese and they also
have a high level of mercury so they
don't recommend eating a ton of them but
they're going to go ahead and tan the
hide and ship it to me so I'm looking
forward to having that in my office well
we're wet and we smell like snake butt
but we've been having a great
time we are home
yay hey guys you guys having fun in the
pool uhhuh oh you having a good birthday
Jacob
yeah
birth
deck happy birthday Jake happy watch a
Pokemon C no do you like your presents
yes well it's been a great day and
Jacob's had a great birthday I think
it's time to put the camera down I'll
see you guys in the morning we're going
alligator
hunting hey Nathan you ready to go
alligator hunting boy from the Gators
love
you oh hey Paul how you doing hey how's
it going man this is Paul and he's with
towns it and Suns Guide Service here and
he's going to take us out we're going to
go fishing for alligators heck yeah man
you ready all right now the way it works
in Florida is private land owners can
have biologists survey the alligator
population on their land and the
biologists will give them a set number
of TXS a number of alligators they can
Harvest and then people like me can come
and pay the land order to harvest their
alligators but make no mistake these are
wild alligators these aren't stocked
alligators they're not fed these are
wild animals so right now we're just
cruising around in the side by side and
we're looking for alligators they get up
to 13 and A2 ft here oh he's right there
on the edge of that grass this one the
little one right on the edge of the
water one yeah yeah do some
practice okay so there's about a 78t
alligator right there he just went down
we can see a little bit of bubbles so
we're going to try to snag him off the
bottom perfect let it
sink all right we're going go try
another
spot like blowing my mind here oh I can
see him I can see his head's facing that
way now yeah there's one basket in the
right there doesn't look too big he's
what maybe 5
ft I tell you to give you know go you
know you're coming they got C on oh we
just saw two 9t Gators sitting on that
island but they kind of slid into the
water when they saw us
coming o that was a long shot well
trying to snag a gator sounds easy in
concept but it's hard in practice stupid
yeah both those gators only gave me one
shot and barely one
shot now be real quiet real quiet we got
to
be there are two big fat Gators over
there a little
further theb tra
you whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa he
going down
okay that wasn't
solid figured this was only a few inches
deep but I stepped here and it goes all
the way up to my
knees I wet my pants told you that first
step there I get you all right but this
spot here you can throw pretty
good
y there you go got him yep got him re
reel re re fast fast fast
fast D like like pull you back
and get a second line his head get we
going to try to get a second hook in him
just to make sure he doesn't get away
and to help get his head up out of the
water all right buddy pull up you pull
that don't let it
go got
him well there we go we got ourselves a
gator man that guy is fat that is a fat
tail yes I think
he look at the size of that tail that is
huge also look at the meat on this thing
this
boy
oh he's moving a little
bit there we go got
him all right we got a gator in the back
we're going to see if we get Nathan
one let's go see if we can get
oh here Nathan come quick buddy yeah
yeah he's going to try to hook him okay
you getting no close to him okay there
was a big one just sitting on that bank
right there and he just dunked in the
water oh there's the bubbles you can see
them right there
gotta lead him oh
man oh Nathan naan come here this is you
he's got him he's on real reel reel reel
reel
reel re reel real fast real hard real
aggressive reel reel reel reel down reel
down son reel
down all right there he is this grass is
worse
let's go check it out buddy say goodbye
to him he's leaving there's your Gator
byebye Snappy I wanted to get him in the
headlock yeah yeah that wasn't going to
happen all right man what you think I
give you high five was that cool you
want to know something what that was
bigger than Tommy's
Gator that was real cool
[Music]
yeah you got kn
sure wait
for watch buddy yeah watch out
buddy that is 82 yeah 8 fo2 about 150 lb
that is a chunky
Gator we're going to go ahead and pick
up the meat in a few days but in the
meantime they're sending me home with a
little bit of alligator rib meat so
we're going to go ahead and have
alligator ribs prob there hey PA that
was a great time well guys that was a
hoot if you guys want to do this too I'm
going to put a link to towns in and Suns
Guide Service in the video description
below well Nathan what did you think of
that was that fun yeah it was really fun
it was cool catching the gator
mhm there you
go well it's been a great day and we're
just sitting here eating dinner and
watching the sunset but I'm going to put
the camera down and I'm going to see you
guys in the
morning all right
we got next to it next you like that
biscuit and gravy sandwich there well
it's a beautiful Sunday we're going to
get the kids dressed and head to church
but before I do I'm putting some
alligator ribs in the
[Applause]
[Music]
oven we got the alligators cooking at a
low slow heat and we're going to let
them sit for about 8 hours forgot to
bring my church shoes so we're going to
wear our extra toughs to church all
right looking good all right
right I think it's time to put the
camera down I'll see you in a little
bit yeah you have a good time at church
yeah oh you can smell the alligator ribs
after I
win for but I think it's time to make
some
dinner
all right we got some alligator ribs
cornbread
peasel macaroni salad grapes dirty beans
and
rice you guys like the food yeah it's
yummy it reminds me of pig meat well
Becca are you having a good day oh a
great D good
down
you like buttermilk pie love ity tell me
what do you think you like it I like
it I'm having a great day happy in
SE wakey wakey up up up get
up well we're heading about 3 hours
North to Crystal River Florida we're
going to go on a charter and go fishing
for oysters and crabs
[Music]
all right guys we're at pets pier in
Crystal River Florida and we're going to
go try to dig some oysters and later
today we're going after crabs hey how
you doing no believe
me we did this same Charter about 3
years ago and Nathan fell in so we got
to make sure we put a life vest on him
even though I fell in I still have
fun
I got this big spike we're going to use
to Anchor ourselves on an oyster
bed is that a oyster just watch that gas
that's a bunch of oysters
no yeah okay we get in here and just
kind
of okay and you try to get some broken
off so this one right here that that's
an oyster so let's just take this one
and we'll measure it real quick and you
measure from the hinge to there so
that's 2 in so that one's not good
enough okay we need 3 in right we need 3
in or better
yep yeah yeah this is a keep well that
looks like a this is a big one yeah you
want to get it right from the hinge but
yeah that one's like a three and a half
right inside there you want to get up
underneath and the way you pop it is by
twisting it you see the water coming out
okay that's your brine you don't want to
lose your brine take your top off all
right and you want to make sure that the
oyster inside is like a light cream
color that looks pretty good well we're
going to try eating
that how's that very good nice that's
fresh that's fresh a salty seab booger
all right put the shell back
in oh there you go bring it up onto the
wooden
board good this is trickier than it
looks it's like playing one of those
arcade claw machines but with
food definitely some in
there K right
there oh well that'll work
too the some are the bugs
living oh hold on Tom oh Tommy got one
Tommy got it's a blue still
cool come on Tommy put him in the Box oh
yeah go get him Nate get it to get it
all right Nate you got that oh
yeah oh that's
heavy oh it isn't it is a fresh one this
one's a keeper here oh we got a keeper
oh yeah keeper right there that's that's
a pretty looking
[Music]
one Jacob have you been throwing the
keepers back crab where just a little
bit give the
screwdriver apparently Jacob and the
boys have been taking the keeper pile
and throwing them overboard we've been
doing a lot of catch and least oyster
harvesting we're we're conservationists
at heart oy save the oysters Sun's
starting to set so we're going to head
back and go crabbing we're going to try
to Dip Net crabs at night how many boys
can you fit on one Mama's
lap we're back at Crystal River in the
sun's setting and so we're going to
start fishing for crabs sen all right
Nathan you ready to get some crabs just
cruising along the shore and we're
looking for blue crabs we see one we're
going to use the net to try to scoop him
up oh there's one right there Tom right
there
oh yeah oh there's one right there Tommy
the little one the little one right
underneath
you oh there's one Tom right there at
the end of your net fast fast fast f f
oh there's big one Tom right on your net
right on your
net yeah we're good spot we good
spot oh oh get him I miss he's over
there he's over
there got him got him yes got him
massive that is a big boy There He
Go all right he put up a ferocious fight
and then you just drop him through the
net there it goes okay once he's like
that you just do it yep that's a nice
crab look at that point to point that
guy six Ines probably big blue
crab
that Dolphins right there dolphins
there's a dolphin circleing the boat
look at they feeding on all these little
fish oh man that's close oh man too
really close the Dolphins are right
there we're
surrounded there he is right there see
him Tom oh yeah okay now wait wait Stick
It Go calmly stick it in the water now
get it down deep and scoop fast forward
fast forward forward forward faster
faster faster faster faster oh now he's
over your way Nathan there he
is there he is oh here's a here's
unrelated one but we'll take
it no well we're seeing plenty of them
you got them NE sweep forward sweep
forward F he
do oh that's a nice little catfish down
therein after us oh another catfish it's
cool all the fish and wildlife you see
at night the seeing red fish and catfish
gar sheep's head all the way to the
bottom you got to do it fast now go for
it fast
that's
oh there you go got it I my size one oh
there you go there is little fur you got
him oh you got him you got you got it
you got
it
exuse no get out get out there we go oh
there's another one oh he's a little far
you you get him you got him I got
him get out get you got him you got him
got him you got
him buddy you got
it woo a shark oh where right there look
there's a shark a shark down get down
behind him sweep forward fast fast I got
him yeah you got
him no no I got I got it's yeah I'm
sorry that's that's the kind of husband
I big
crap you're not getting away he I don't
know he looks like he is stop right
there he's so tiny oh there's another
one oh nice one Tom no way there's
another one no no charity crab all
righty Toby you digging this I loving it
me too every oh there's one right under
your net count you got them Nathan don't
drop it on me there you go oh I got him
dad's winning you get him yeah guys I
got bad news what it's time to call it
we got to get you to
bed more
please guys is this one of your favorite
things to do yes this is this is one of
our favorite family Chargers to do this
is a hoot dad plus 4 plus two I mean
that's not amazing but considering how
cold that is right now and how many we
missed that's pretty good there's some
good size guys in there too I think I'm
going to let these these little guys go
yeah pinch them by the
flippers yeah he's going to get a piece
of you Tom want big Bo do all right guys
sit down we got to head
back all right you know how to pick
these up so you go over here and you
pinch their little flippers in the back
and then they can't get get you I'm
afraid of Cl oh they're just giant
spiders with
pinchers that's a cool idea no if you
guys are ever near Crystal River Florida
and you want to do this too check out
Florida crabbing Charters and I'll put a
link in the video description below come
BL we just got checked into the hotel
it's late I got to get kids to bed I'll
see you guys in the
morning
good
morning hey Becca you like your
food all right guys you ready we got a
lot of driving to do let's
go we're driving 6 hours south to kargo
Florida then your destination will be on
the
left oh well we are hungry we're going
to grab some
lunch
oh this right here is chichon fried pig
SK
leave naan what's inside
yours
a oh it's potato and meat inside it's
really good
mom try that's like a sweet cream cheese
in there that is good look at that
grilled cheese sandwich that is so good
look
at this is a vanilla eair and this is a
keyme tart man using a cream Center y it
feel taste that best thing I've ever
tasted in my life Cent so good love that
what do you guys think you guys like
that it was
good if you want to try this place out
it's the Tropical Bakery Cafe and
Restaurant I'll put a link in the video
description below oh food was great and
the people were so
nice going to
Miami
[Music]
look at this this is snazzy welcome to
kilargo this rental house is on one acre
of land that's unheard of here in the
keys look at this Tomy got
boats look at that got their own Pier
looks like Tommy's wasting no time oh to
see we go I no you you want us
to there you go buddy and they said
don't well after a long day in the car
this looks like a pretty nice place to
watch the
sunset what do you think Becca you think
the kids are going to like this oh
they're going to love it they're already
in the water me and Becca are getting up
early to go scuba diving and spear
fishing tomorrow morning so I got to put
this camera up and I'll see you guys in
the
morning
that's what I mean by like
equipment how we doing I'm doing well
how are you
doing
between all right guys we're here with
Jeff and Luke and we're going with
forever young spear fishing and we're
going to go out scuba diving and spear
fishing out here in the keys and we are
so excited this is our what third time
doing this I think I think
so all right Becky you ready for this
all right now the water temperature is
69° f so it's uh it's a little
nippy you ready to do this Becca
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
you
it's loaded
stillo I've seen those pictures look at
that there we go yeah you shot you shot
three of those lion fish huh yeah
congratulations these are an invasive
lion fish they're native to the Indian
Ocean they're also venomous they've got
these poisonous spines on each one of
these long fins and you can kind of see
if you look close there's a thin oh
really tiny little yeah but uh you've
been stung before quite a few times you
live to tell the tale huh to tell the
tail but it'll make you feel like you
didn't but they're a tasty fish and uh
so we're going to shoot as many of those
as we see and we'll we'll eat those up
how you doing are you
cold a little bit where the
ne but we brought hot chicken noodle
soup it's warm I love
it
we're at about 34 ft of water this time
and we're going to drop some Chum out
see if we can't bring the fish
up all right we're anchored up we're
going to let the chum do its thing and
I'm just going to try to stop
shivering
yeah
not seen much more than what you seen
no I am a bit cold I think we're call It
Go in a little bit early and warm up
that's
it you have fun babe had a great time
good oh it feels good to get
dry I'll cut the spines off first so I
don't stab myself yeah it sounds like a
good
move
once again my wife has outfished me this
is the third time we've done this
Charter and this is definitely the
coldest it's ever been but I still had a
really good time it is January it is
January lizen if you guys want to do
this too check out forever young spear
fishing I'll put a link in the video
description
below Becca are you tired yeah I'm
exhausted all right we're going to go
see if we can find a restaurant that's
going to cook up Becca's lion
fish we're going to go eat at the con
house here in
kilargo Gates Gator bites look at that
so we got coconut shrimp Gator bites and
con hey Jacob do you like your con
Fritter yeah you know that comes from a
sea
snail
wow wow oh wow that's cool look at that
we got all the lion fish fried up you
can eat the fins you guys like you just
ate the poisonous spine of a lion fish
is it good oh not a spine but a
fish I got a lime fish is good oh my
goodness look at that oh my goodness got
a key lime coconut
cake Jacob did you eat that not all by
myself all
right okay oh guys it's been a great day
but it is late and time to put up the
camera I'll see you guys in the
morning well guys it is a beautiful
lowkey day here in kilargo Tommy's going
to take me out in The Kayaks
okay
see we got
our that
yeah there we go left their water bottle
that's it nice to yeah there's another
shipwreck over there you want to go
explore that one
check it out someone tied up this little
dock up to it so they can unload stuff
off it you know it looks pretty trash
there's a refrigerator
inside let's see check it
out there's plants growing in the
upholstery should be
easy hi
Captain well Tom that was a good idea
that was fun
bud
naan
naan oh ow those kind of hurt I think
it's time to go make some
[Music]
lunch here you go
Bud look at how many there are
there we go nice little pile of crab
meat we're going to have crab mac and
cheese got a little Jamaican meat pocket
to go with our crab mac and
cheese this a Jamaican meat pocket try
that you like the meat
pocket all righty we got a roll we're
going to be meeting up with Goa from the
YouTube channel googa
Foods hello
nice to meet you brother ni too a lovely
Place holy mackerel you've got a lot of
grills what is that a smoker grill this
is the smoker over here more barbecues
over there a be freezer it's a little
empty oh my
goodness oh like do you order this stuff
on the internet mostly or I have a meat
dealer pretty much everything that's
more camera equipment than I've ever
owned right there so I built this whole
entire building from nothing if if you
think I do cooking videos no no no no
googa googa does cooking hey so we got a
few things here for you guys to try I
don't know if you ever well you've been
to Japan so I'm sure you had a five wagy
right I'm sure not as good as what
you're about to make
though mind you like the tin foil on you
go you get tin foil I stick it in there
so I noticed no sizzling when you put it
on no sizling oh cuz then it that lets
it cool down exactly so oh look at
that is looking good good job
Tom it makes me we we just walking in
the look at that you can be a hand model
there you go rare I will steal it out of
your hands that's the best stick I've
ever tasted I've been doing it wrong my
whole
life grab some utensil not go for
it going to front is a GoPro all right I
guess we're going to we're going to film
a react video is that right yeah a
reaction video I'm going to put a link
in the video description below to this
video on goa's channel so make sure to
check that out well that was fun thank
you very much thanks for coming for
thank you it was such a pleasure
absolutely when you come back let me
know oh I missed you Jake well listen
guys it's late I got to get some kids to
bed I'm going to put the camera down
I'll see you in the morning we're
getting up
early
oh
come on Tom wakey
wakey hey good morning morning well the
weather forecast surprised us a little
bit and uh we got four to six foot waves
and so doing a 2hour jog through that
sounds a bit rough with the kids so I
think we're gonna have to cancel today
so we're gonna see some of Key West
instead yeah we're gonna pivot all right
guys let's go get some breakfast we're
going to go to the dolphin Deli for some
breakfast oh I'm so
tired
do hey the sou most point in the US a
couple years ago me and the boys we
drove from here all the way to the
Arctic Ocean in Dead Horse Alaska go
10,200 Mi did a video on it smile there
you go all
right oh what is this button do we're
here at Fort Zachary Taylor I think I
know why it's yeah check out the
blacksmith shop so Fort Taylor was built
in 1845 and used by the union during the
Civil War and was also used during World
War II just in look how thick those
walls are guys work right three
artillery shells and cannon
[Applause]
balls I don't think I explain what we
were going to do this morning we were
planning on taking a charter all the way
to the dry Tortuga Islands we're going
to go snorkeling and spear fishing it's
this remote fort on an island out in the
middle of the keys but the weather was
really bad and we didn't feel like being
in a boat for 5 hours with uh rough wind
and waves
so turn right
onel time to get a golf cart that's what
I wanted
no the
mus doing
good yeah well don't worry no one's
going to steal it I got a bike lock the
bike
walk all right I I think it's time to do
all the touristy stuff in Key
West should we do this Shipwreck Museum
it's right in here prepared to
enter oh see this is bar shot they would
shoot it out of a cannon it would take
out all the ropes on a ship say 64 PB
Bar of silver it's worth thousands of
dollars oh I got
it what is
that come on Mama you can do it
this is the highest
VI go check out an
aquarium but this is what Kong fritters
are made out
of look those
[Music]
TP there's
the poisonous it's a scorpion
fish well with the humidity you're 6ot
and large eyee they have a silver tail
pit all right guys we're going to check
out the mfisher Maritime Museum Mel
Fisher was a treasure hunter who
discovered one of the richest Sunken
Treasures in this area
B
yeah from the ship yeah from a shipwreck
that's a $25,000 brick of silver right
there weighs 70 lbes everything each one
of these bars of silver is worth about
$20,000 look at that gold that's pretty
big for it's little Dr
Evil oh you can see look at the helmets
why just Blackness pirate guns
mil should we go to
lunch these are so small o hully hully
chicken burer Hawaii and pull pork and
rice
nice that okay okay I
[Music]
just all right guys grab the stuff well
that was fun did you guys enjoy that
yeah I had a good time it wasn't what we
planned but it was fun it was fun it
worked out well I think it's time to
head back to kilargo I'm going to pass
out I'm so
tired it's been a long day I'll see you
in the
morning all right we're going to go get
some
breakfast any of those look good maybe
yeah Mommy would like
that all right guys this smells amazing
if you guys are in Karo check out Pine
CR Bakery there we go down and
uh to feed the I hope you're hungry cuz
there was a communication glitch and we
over ordered look at that oh look at
this uh Becca oh my goodness we might
have over ordered a caramel Clair oh I'm
so excited so this is mostly sweet
there's some sweet stuff in here these
are Savory this is why you don't send a
hungry guy with limited Spanish to the
bakery
amazing what is it's like a buttery
croissant with a beef filling this
croquet is like cheesy mashed potatoes
oh it's like honey and cheese oh
no oh like ham and cheese breakfast was
good but now it's time to pack up and
get heading
[Music]
home
there we go fried alligator and Japanese
curry with a little bit of s
Becca do you like the gator meat it's
really good well guys that was a
wonderful adventure and hopefully you
guys enjoyed this video if you guys want
to see more of our travel Adventures we
have videos from all over the world
check out our Travel and Adventure
playlist and don't forget to click
subscribe all right guys I'll see you
next video If you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every Saturday
morning and hit that Bell button so
you'll get notification thanks for
watching